il est l'heure d'afficher le nom des
lauréats le calme à l'intérieur
et pour une fois à l'extérieur aussi
voulaient pas regarder sur internet vous
préférez me revoir au lycée bien raison
les élèves ont été convoqués par classe
et les résultats affichés dans deux
endroits du lycée drôle d'ambiance pour
un drôle de bach ce qu'ils ont là
maintenant ils ont travaillé toute
l'année et donc on soit il est
récompensé aussi mais après c'est sûr
qu'on appelle les épreuves on n'a pas eu
besoin de rattraper de voir tous les
chapitres précédemment donc en soi aussi
c était peut-être un peu plus facile
c'est pas le même bac en fait mais ça
reste un bac pas de liesse pas
d'embrassades mais pas que des reçus non
plus non le bac 2020 n'a pas été donnée
tout le monde ne l'a pas il ya eu des
jurys tous les livrets scolaires ont été
étudiés et y compris à partir du travail
qui a pu être fournies au troisième
trimestre même si a pas une note
donc c'est un bac dans des circonstances
effectivement tout à fait différente de
d'habitude mais je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire que ce bac ne vaut rien je
me souviens du coup on a payé pour
m'habiller bien particulier pour rien
c'était sûr fait
non c'était bien de venir ici quand même
ouais ouais c'est côté émotion sa numéro
3 ça fait toujours pareil avant de
quitter définitivement le lycée les tout
nouveaux bacheliers récupèrent leur
relevé de notes
une page se tourne pour eux et avec eux
fini les séries en 2021 c'est le nouveau
bac qui entrera en vigueur